everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse today we're going to do something
that we've never done before on the
stream we're going to work with
Salesforce in particular we're going to
edit some visualforce pages so I'm going
to start out with a little introduction
of Salesforce since we've never used it
before you may not be familiar with it
so sales forces as a product is huge and
does a lot of different things so I'm
only going to talk about the little
piece that we're going to work with
because I'm definitely not a an expert
on Salesforce it would take quite a lot
of research and training to learn it you
know everything that it can do so I've
learned enough to be able to do what
we're gonna do today and even if you
have no idea about Salesforce or what it
does as long as you know basic HTML and
CSS you'll be able to follow this string
cuz that's really what we're going to
deal with maybe we use some JavaScript
we'll see I don't think we'll need to
but you never know so Salesforce
basically it's it's mostly used by
companies who want to track like leads
customers right so a marketing tool we
at the university that work at use it a
little bit differently in that the
university you don't have customers in
the same sense that maybe another
company would have you know like a
retail store or something so we have a
prospective students right so students
usually high school students who are
interested in coming to to our schools
so there are various ways that they
reach out to us so we have an inquiry
form for those students who are just you
know kind of interested but then we also
have an online
an application that's what we're gonna
be working on today and so what happens
is when we have a student who's
interested in coming here they get into
the Salesforce system and then they're
put into categories and there's data
available for our admissions counselors
it gets them into let's say like what
you'd normally call a sales funnel
although we don't really consider its
sales and as they progress through the
stages and then different things might
happen they might get different
materials so let's see it looks like
there's audio popping all right let me
try to move my chords around and get
them away from my mic all right let me
know if you're still getting the pocket
that's odd some days I think it has to
do with where I'm putting my phone and
where the my phones usually plugged into
my computer it usually has to do with
where it is some days it's fine and
other days it's two-hour anyway it's
Fitz fix that's cool but anyway we're
going to deal with that part of the
process where a student has decided that
they're interested enough in our
university that they actually want to
fill out an application to go here so we
need to work on this application right
now we're using an application that does
funnel data into Salesforce eventually I
did a lot of work on the current
application to get it looking as nice as
I possibly could but there were a lot of
limitations so I have no direct access
so I guess I could it would be better if
I showed you the current application
instead of just talking about it so the
URL is not easy to remember so I'm going
to go in through this way supply okay
so the application to look at it is not
terrible it actually shares a lot of the
styles that you've seen that we've
worked on in other other applications so
the header should look familiar the
white you know the three pixel gold
border the shadows even the shadows on
the card so everything is is the same
even you know this material design style
of the of the inputs so this was all
done though with CSS that had to
override what was already in there so
all the only access I have to this is I
was able to have the company that made
this put in a link to a CSS file on a
server that I do
the popping is back you know what I'm
just gonna unplug my phone completely
and put it somewhere else let's put my
foot over here all right
so my phone I just now threw it in a
chair on the other side of the room so
if the popping is still there we'll know
it's not my phone at least if if the
popping is still there after that then
I'll switch up to the the built-in mic
on the iMac I think we try to fix this
on another stream and I figure okay it's
good now all right if it comes back
please let me know I'll just quit using
this mic let's see where was that I got
I got off-track oh okay we're looking at
this so basically the problem is I only
can just do CSS work to it so I was
limited in what I really could do like
you know these inputs there there are
little things that I couldn't make it
exactly like the other the other forms
okay and then on the back end of things
there are some other some other problems
and I'm not going to go through this
form now but basically you need a
there's a page refresh that happens
every time you go to a different page so
it's not a modern experience like you
would get in a progressive web app or a
single page application where you know
you'd be able to navigate around without
having the page refresh happen all the
time so you you understand what I'm
saying I mean the technologies are I
don't know how you can see that or not
but I mean it's it's jQuery base so the
new application we can see we're getting
a little bit better here still using
some jQuery stuff which is
understandable everybody uses jQuery but
at least we're using a more modern
responsive framework so they're actually
using bootstrap for this okay so not bad
so what we need to do then is change
these default styles to match up more in
line something like this it's not gonna
look exactly the same but we need to use
those same styles we've been using on
all our projects it's going to be a
little bit different though because
we're not gonna have our normal dev
environment set up we're gonna have like
I just looked check the live chat and
are sure that's what extension that is
it's wet lap eliezer w APPA al y zer so
I'll type that into the live chat so
anyway that extension is pretty
convenient to be able to just see what's
with you don't really have to look at
the code just with a click you can see
what a website is built with so I'm
always curious to see how people do
things so this lets me just take a look
quickly okay so that's basically you
know what we're gonna do we're just
going to try to get as much done as
possible I don't expect to be able to
get everything styled you know properly
in here but for today it would be nice
if we could get the header looking like
the standard header that we've had the
white header with the web logo on our
gold border at the bottom and the
correct shadow also we need to figure
out what we're gonna do with this area
here I'm not sure how I feel about this
yet so maybe you can try a couple
different things out I'll tell you what
I'm thinkin so y'all can think about it
though III see basically two options
here I I don't like just this little
strip of a of an image to be honest with
you this page right here is just to sign
up actually this is
is me go to the first page login
I think the first page is the login page
ok this is the first page users will see
the whole point is login so why do we
have this big image and title here and
push the login down far go to the bottom
right the user needs to login they're
not here to look at images so I'm
thinking either completely get rid of
the image and just have a very very
simple login screen that it's obvious
right away login here there's nothing
else you can do just login or make some
type of full screen background image
with the login floating on top of it
that way at least the login will stand
out more and we'll have the image and
the image will obviously be the not the
focus it will be in the background and
the focus of everything will be the sign
and so either way my goal is to have the
sign-in card be the focus so y'all can
let me know what you think when we get
to that point first things first let's
get this header in better shape so let
me pull over where do I have it
yea let me pull over this Salesforce
page
and also let me know what the quality of
the video is so YouTube changed how you
do live streaming and you used to have
the option to set beforehand what
quality you wanted the video to be but
now they took it away and I guess they
automatically detect it I want to make
sure that we're still able to get 1080p
video so I'm trying to check the
analytics it looks like some of you are
watching in 1080p so I assume since
that's happening then from my end it's
it's alright I'm over five five thousand
kilobits per second so I'm it should be
good enough for at 1080p okay so this is
what we'll be working with as our file
so within Salesforce so if this is the
old-school view of Salesforce so they do
have an updated UI my organization is
not switched over to the updated UI yet
I can do a preview of it if I really
want to but by default I still see the
old views so if you are using Salesforce
if you're a version of Salesforce may
look different the how I got to here so
probably may not be a big deal if you
don't use Salesforce but in case you do
I'll just quickly go over how I got here
so up in the upper right hand corner for
me there is a setup if you're using the
newer version there'll be a little
Settings icon you know like the little
looks like a gear within the settings
icon then you can click setup either way
once you get to setup you go over here
it's gonna look different depending on
the version but they'll still be this
this sidebar here and you want to go to
develop and then expand that and go to
visualforce pages then you're going to
be given a huge list of available pages
figure out what page you want click it
and then you're in here the first screen
you get won't be this it'll it'll show
some info
but it's not editable if you have the
proper level of permissions in
Salesforce there'll be an edit button
click Edit and that's how you get into
here so I know that was really fast
I just don't spend that much time on it
if anybody wants to talk about it more
later on let me know during the question
and answer session let's see I'm trying
to find my my timer so don't forget here
we go and I will bring it up here
ok so let's set that 25 minute timer and
get to work
ok so I need to figure out a way to make
this look a little nicer actually let me
pull this out let's pull all this code
out and put it in a code editor it'll be
a lot easier to see it in a proper
editor so I'm just gonna pull this into
this page and let's set since this is
HTML hopefully it'll it'll deal with
these custom tags
yeah that's not about it it looks like
it's dealt properly with some of these
custom tags so basically Salesforce has
their own I guess maybe like a
templating system it's this apex so a PE
X right so they have these apex tags so
think of this as I don't know if I want
to call them exactly components like in
the react if you have components but I
it's somewhat like that
alright so it operates something like
that we could see that it allows us to
insert you know variables dynamic
content into the HTML so I guess in a
sense it does it's you could think of in
a similar way teraz react lets you mix
javascript in the HTML I know it's
really not that it's it's more you put
HTML and a JavaScript function
but this is a similar thing that we get
to put programming concepts right in
this case variables into into HTML we're
not really going to be messing with that
that much though I don't want to mess
with what this does by default what I do
want to change is the container the HTML
shell that's around this so let's see I
just remembered I didn't really check
the live chat yet so hey everybody just
want to see what's going on quickly
before I start okay
so let's just briefly go through some of
this you can see this looks aside from
all these apex tags it's a basic HTML
page right you have your HTML at your
head title tag you know all your links
that are bringing in write your icons
your JavaScript CSS C we're bringing in
bootstrap here they do have some custom
CSS where I have been unable to locate
in Salesforce where this file is this
target X dot CSS I would love to be able
to just edit this file directly but I
can't find it and I've already spent too
much time looking for it so I've just
given up on that and we're just gonna
add our own CSS and we may end up
putting it in a style tag or we could
link to it from something else we'll see
I can see pros and cons to either way
alright so now we get to the body I just
put in this class body test just to make
sure I had there were a few templates
that were all named very similar names
so I needed to make sure which one was
actually the active template so that's
why I've added this in so I'm gonna
remove this now since it served its
purpose whoops I went to save it well
what I'll do is maybe we can make
changes here with art so we could use
our editor and then at periodically
we'll just copy and paste everything
into here so I realize changes I make
here are gonna do anything yet but I
think that'll allow us to take advantage
of some of what we the features we have
in our code editor it'll probably be
easier in the long run to do it like
that ok so we have our nav component and
and remember - if you used to bootstrap
try to think in in bootstrap mode in
terms of when you see some of these
classes they may be familiar to you now
this page is actually really basic and
that mo
of the markup is going to be injected
you know with with these apex tags so
we're not gonna be able to see
everything we may have to do some
digging if we really want to change
something but I think we'll be able to
get a lot done with the combination of
this template and chrome dev tools and
we may not even have to dig in and find
these files this actually feels very
similar to what we are doing with that
dotnet framework main website page that
we were working on a few weeks ago okay
so alright so we have some things
comment it out okay so this file
actually you can see is very very simple
like I said really at this point all
we're gonna be doing with it is using it
to add in some of our styles so let's
get to work on picking out some of the
things that we want to change so we're
gonna go in with dev tools I am for this
particular window I'm using Chrome
Canary if you're not familiar with
Chrome Canary it's the latest version of
Chrome I don't know that it's
necessarily like the cutting-edge
version they might there might be a
better version but it's pretty stable
and it allowed the reason I like to use
this sometimes is that it gives you
access to new features and dev tools
before they are released into regular
chrome when I'm testing a site I like to
use the regular version of Chrome
because the odds of a user actually
using Chrome Canary are super low so
anyway so my dev tools may look a little
bit different than yours and actually
let me let me copy and paste this into
the live chat the link I didn't test to
see if this was available to everyone
but I assume it is I guess I could let's
see
alright yeah that should be available to
everyone
actually let's update our Chrome Canary
write it canary has updates so
frequently which is ok you can see it
only took a second to update ok now
let's go into our dev tools and let me
try to get this so I'm not worried about
these errors because I really can't do
much about them anyway like I said there
are some files that I have not been able
to find so I can't fix that so let's
save some space and just minimize that
and let me know is this font size too
small in dev tools I can probably expand
it a bit and make it a little bigger I'm
afraid if I get too big we just won't be
able to see things all right so let's
try to target this a nav bar and I've
already the only thing I've done is I've
pulled in the low the proper logo and
I'm actually I'm maybe going to find a
better solution than this but right now
I'm just linking directly to the logo
that's on that Resource Center that we
that we built maybe a month or so ago ok
so we're gonna have that's interesting
so it looks like we're gonna go the nav
component itself
yeah the napkin phone is what we want
yeah ok
so here in the nav component let's
change some what we're doing we don't
want a border at all so I don't think
yeah first let's let's do some things to
cancel out some of the styles that are
in there you can see these are coming
from bootstrap I have no desire to edit
bootstrap directly I think that's a
mistake
so let's just work with what we have so
we're gonna go border:none so we have no
border there but then now we want to do
a border bottom and we're gonna go with
three pixels solid and we need to grab
that gold color and I always forget what
it is so where is it this is the fastest
way for me to get this gold color
probably in this project that's fine CSS
we don't anything in our CSS
let's see if I can find where we use
this
then we put in our app bar
nope do not put it in here
I do not remember where we put all of
the styles
a few guys theme that's gotta be it we
didn't even put it in there alright
enough of that that's a waste waste of
time let's go here and just inspect this
one
very an h1 really that whole things in H
tag you see what kind of ridiculous
stuff happens sometimes when you don't
have control over the markup my entire
at bar at the top is an h1 tag it's
insane
it's an h1 to anyway
that stuff just it just amazes me
sometimes but this is actually this is
what I had to do to make an AB bar the
only element that would work for this
was an h1 so anyway uh-huh that's just
that's just the way it is sometimes you
gotta work with what you have okay
bringing back all these memories of when
I actually did that work and how
frustrating it was it's it's a mix of
fun and frustration it's fun because
it's like I can't believe I just took
this crazy markup and it made something
that looked decent with it and then
frustration because it's like all I need
is a div right here and you can't do
anything you can't put the div in okay
cool so we have our border at the bottom
now we need our shadows so let's grab
we could check the shadows here yeah I
guess we'll just use these shadows I do
want to make sure that they match
actually these do look like the newer
shadows initially we use slightly
different values and I'm talking like
maybe a year ago or something we had
slightly different shadow values and
then materialized CSS updated and added
a third line here in their box shadow
and so I don't I don't remember what we
updated what we didn't so anyway that
does look good that looks like the right
values so let's use those so we're gonna
throw in this whoa it's not let me paste
that in that's let's try again
we're just gonna grab the values this
son and we'll type box shadow on our own
sometimes paste thing into dev tools can
be a little weird if you paste if you
accidentally paste the wrong stuff it
just rejects it yes it worked that time
awesome whoa maybe it didn't what did I
do
oh I type accidentally Ted bucks sizing
box shadow that's what we want okay
great and that should work let's check
back here we can't really see it but
there should be a shadow you can
slightly see the shadow so all right
cool so we have that down the basics
down there it's not what I wanted so
let's grab these and pull them over huh
I'm actually not sure what the best way
to to do these styles is you know what
let's um
for now let's just open up another
another file here and whoops let's let's
just start putting styles in a file and
then that way we don't have to make a
decision on where to put the styles and
yet never yeah let's just use nav bar
dot nav are there we go okay
actually let me save this in case
something happens and I guess I should
say this is a project so let's make a
new folder and call this so forth yeah
I'll just call it Salesforce and let's
go application dot CSS okay cool
so now we can
let's try to make this logo look like it
should look so we need every nerve
container assuming it's in here
there we go so target X header
University icon wow that that is quite a
quite a large class so I'm just gonna
paste that class in here right now
so now we're gonna be using that and
let's see it's just it's simply a
background image so you can see the
background image it goes back to this
default so we're gonna take that
background image and we're definitely
going to keep that at least for now
we're gonna keep that that URL so we'll
have that in our file now what we want
to do is add in some some options here
see you check my timer
alright good eleven minutes
let's see so wow it's been a while since
I just did straight-up CSS its
background
[Music]
let's go background repeat' cuz we
definitely don't want to repeat no
repeat
and then background is it sighs there's
so many background properties there we
go that's what I wanted sighs cover
contain container I don't want
I guess contain is what we want for now
and then okay we need to set it with
let's go with actually
there we go that looks good let's check
that out for a minute okay what's that
sighs look actually I like that sighs
that's not too bad let me see what it
looks like here nice
all right that's actually it was a
breakpoint I think we'll be fine even
great all right I really like that I
think that's perfect so let's let's copy
this over and paste it I do want to see
if we even need this no repeat that's
yep we definitely need that I was hoping
we we didn't need it when we put the
contain on but we will so always worth
it to try to save a line of code though
there we go okay awesome all right so it
looks like our header is looking a lot
closer to what we our standard header is
now we definitely want to change I don't
mind this this online application I
actually really like this font off to
double check and see what font this is
I'm just I'm interested in seeing what
they have loaded already let's see the
font family hi it's just open sans that
looks really nice being being thin like
that obviously we're going to import
Roboto that's the font that we use for
everything I'm not going to do it right
now though we'll see how things go so I
think with let's change this to that
green color the font color to green and
then we'll change these icons to green I
hope I just got to do this I really
really hope these are font icons or
SVG's if not we're gonna totally replace
these icons actually we might replace
these icons no matter what
before we're using
an interesting
huh really interesting okay
so here's what I'd like to do I'm a just
now I think about it I may actually just
remove the icons I don't think we need
any icons there sign up and log in or
find the thing here's the one thing I
did not like about those icons okay
obviously those weren't material design
so icons but aside from that it seemed
to me like that icon was supposed to be
a male a silhouette of a male head okay
so I would rather use an icon for a
person that would be gender-neutral
that's just a personal preference for me
and I think I think users would
appreciate that even if it's just they
don't realize it I I prefer to do it
like that so in this case I actually
like it better without the icons I think
the icon and the text was unnecessary
so let's while we're down here let's
grab all this and we're gonna reset the
content
let me grab all this
and calendar before email before you had
our user all right let's get rid of this
because I don't want to mess with those
yet what I do want to worry about is
this header user before now I'm assuming
that that's what this is content and
then we're just gonna give it that let's
double check target X header user yep
that is what we wanted okay great so now
that's gonna remove that for us while
we're down here let's um let's see where
we're getting the font color from target
X header you so it is in fact on that
target X header user okay so we're gonna
have to grab this header print counter
you know you know what let's grab all
this and change the color of it
ok this will be that green color so
actually I used to have the highlight
that worked an atom that showed the
color but it was throwing all kind of
errors it's the pigments is the the
package and it's thrown all kind of
errors so I turned it off so you can't
see the color that was always nice but
not necessary ok great so that should be
fine for the font color let's let's just
change it here just so that we can get a
nice visual okay there we go and
all right let's see what we have here
where we're getting that color from
Target etc university name great let's
just add this here we can manually add
it in here just so we can see it great
okay now I'm gonna change the font the
font way the size probably at some point
for now this is okay I just want to see
what the colors look like and I want to
see what the color looks like for this
online application but I think the gray
might it might work out it might look
nice with the gray so we're gonna try it
but maybe we'll switch it back so let's
see actually let me do this
I'm gonna add in an another attribute
and that way we can switch back and
forth 52 colors more easily okay so
here's the green let's zoom out because
a user will almost never be zoomed in
that much and we're going to toggle back
and forth
hmm interesting I'm not I'm not sure
that I have a preference by their way so
here's what I'm going to do let's put
this in here and
we'll just make a little note so that
later on we can make a decision on that
okay my timer is up so I'm going to do
five minutes of question-and-answer in
the live chat and then we'll do another
25-minute session of just some CSS this
is actually pretty fun for me I I mean I
started out doing a lot of CSS just like
this people would come to me with
existing sites that needed work done and
I would go in there and just try to make
the best of it so this is very like
natural and fun for me so I'm having a
good time hopefully you are enjoying it
as well I read an article yesterday I
forget where it was from but the article
was someone recalling a conversation
they had with a person who was
attempting to hire developers that could
work with just regular HTML and CSS they
said they were having trouble finding
people like that they could find people
that knew how to use frameworks they
could use angular react view and do
really well but anytime they asked him
to do just a simple basic CSS change or
vanilla JavaScript change they couldn't
do it and I that was really interesting
to me because I haven't had that
experience I came up through doing just
normal CSS and JavaScript before I
started with react and different
frameworks so but they were saying
because of coding boot camps there are a
lot of people a lot of developers now
that are coming through the coding boot
camps they focus on the frameworks like
react or angular and you learn that and
to save time because they need to get in
so much material they skip over a lot of
the basics you know why learn CSS if you
could just use bootstrap right or some
component library so anyway I thought
that was interesting so maybe I'll try
to occasionally throw in some basic CSS
stuff like this because evidently
there's some there's some need for it in
some
cases let's see
okay I'm bear to saying the image looks
very gloomy are you talking about this
image in the background I think at that
point in the stream we were talking
about this image so potentially yeah
actually this image is the default stock
photo that came with this this
application so we we hired a third-party
company that's not Salesforce but they
developed this for Salesforce and this
is their default thing so I don't even
know what school this is but we're
definitely gonna if we keep an image we
are going to take that out actually I
just made up my mind we're not gonna
have an image in it first if people
higher up than me tell me I need to put
an image back in I will but we're gonna
save so much time by not having to go
through images and pick what image we
want for this and then edit the image
okay so let's just let's just do that
and then of course I would want to have
responsive images so I would want
multiple crops and sizes so that's we're
gonna save a lot of time no no oh man
almost locked me out okay
oh cool so Michael Creole says my first
time watching you live awesome thank you
for joining us hopefully you're still
joining us I know you sent that message
a while ago about a half hour ago yeah
but that's awesome I'm so glad that you
could you could join us live and thanks
for letting me know so feel free to send
me any comments or questions that you
have and I'd love to hear more from you
Harshit says I guess Salesforce is the
company who made Heroku oh really I did
not remember that that's cool yeah
Salesforce is a really big company they
just either built or bought one of the
biggest buildings in San Francisco for
their headquarters so they're quite
quite a successful company right now a
harsh it says the editor looks like
notepad plus plus yeah does it
definitely looks like notepad plus plus
I was not in a hurry to use that that
built-in editor
okay I see something about font size let
me increase that font size again oh
maybe we'll have to extend this a little
bit all right
maybe right there we'll be all right Oh
Michael says here in the woods of
Mississippi I'm struggling to get 360
probably not your fault oh man I'm sorry
that must be really hard to see
everything I'll do my best to describe
everything because I it's probably tough
to see it on 360 we'll talk about video
quality so anyway Michael uh awesome
you're from Mississippi I don't recall
anyone ever on the stream saying that
they're from Mississippi so you might be
the first person well harsh it's in the
Himalayas I'm not sure if I had anybody
say they're in the Himalayas before so
that's that's cool
all right so my timer is up I'm gonna
grab a pen and write down where I'm
going to leave off here in the live chat
so I can find it more quickly later on
and let's do another 25-minute coding
session and the first thing that we're
going to do first thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna grab this code and that
we just did so all this and we're gonna
put it in and see if it works I
definitely want to test it periodically
because I'm not sure if this is enough
to override the styles that are in there
right now sometimes you never know what
gets injected into the page in line that
could be overriding thing so now's a
great time since we've finished this one
component here I think now's a great
time to check that out we don't want to
forget though there is this drop-down
menu so oh great okay I was worried that
it would it would mess up a lot when we
changed our Styles you know what I think
this is fine the only thing that I'm
gonna change about this is I don't want
I want this to not have a background and
I want this icon to be green
let's go ahead and change that now and
then we'll check it we'll check out the
code so icon bar okay so the for the
icon bar or default never tell you icon
bar all right let's change this to 2a
oh goodness this is how they did it
oops that's not what I wanted I'd wait a
second hold on
this is so interesting okay bordercolor
all right let's get rid of that border
so no border color none will that work
no we're gonna have to go transparent
okay so let's let's throw this in here
now so we're gonna have several elements
they're gonna have to edit so let's go
with border-color:transparent for that
navbar and then this is taller
navigation that's for the screen reader
so see this is s our only screen reader
only and then it has text so that a
screen reader when it gets to this we'll
say it's the toggle navigation so that's
useful for people who can't see or have
trouble seeing and it's it's a good it's
always good to think about that when
you're developing so I think it's
something that is really easy to forget
but it's so important for people with
disabilities to be able to have access
to the site it may not seem like a big
deal but to that person it's a huge deal
all right so did that actually show up
as green now it did yeah it was just a
bit hard to see I want to double-check
what we're using on our other sites in
terms of border-radius for these so
let's let's quickly go to
let's go to the resource center and
let's check this out it's not let me
zoom why not now that's weird
there we go my trackpad has been acting
a bit weird okay so it looks like
there's no border-radius on those so
let's change that up I'm gonna leave
this open so we can reference it more
quickly whoops there we go okay so now
back to here let's change our border
radius to zero there we go now we have
the look that we want great so let's
take this just grab this and we're gonna
grab this one so anyway if I sounded
somewhat amazed when I first looked at
this and that was because I realized
that this is not a font icon or an SVG
this is in fact three spans that just
have a background color but yeah that's
so interesting and actually you could do
quite a lot with this since it's three
spans I mean you could use some CSS
animations to do some really cool
animation things I've seen cool things
done with these before so we're not
going to do anything like that right now
but it's just kind of cool to see it
done like that I've seen it before but I
never do it like this so it's just is
kind of interesting to see how other
people do that and okay I didn't copy
that yet okay and we can remove these
because we don't really want to change
that all right now I think it's time to
test this out so let's copy everything
that we have here and let me let's paste
it in so let's find a good spot here in
the head to put in oops
you know what I forgot that's not how
our flow is going to go it's good too
have a good workflow so things don't get
messed up so I have a lot of experience
with having to work with old systems or
within these other systems and so you
kind of have to just improvise a
workflow since you can't have it ideally
the way you want so here's the workflow
what the workflow is going to be we're
always going to edit this file first and
then copy and paste everything over that
way we can have a copy locally and
actually I'm going to need let's just
save this now in our projects under
Salesforce so let's call this app
template dot HTML great now let's create
a style tag and then we can paste in all
our Styles now we'll copy everything
over and paste it all in this will it's
it might seem kind of weird to do this
now but if we start editing multiple
places in here and going back in and
trying to edit things it's going to get
difficult it's much easier to just every
single time we do something completely
replace everything then trying to scroll
through and find the exact spot where we
need to edit things so in the long run
the feedback loop is going to be much
shorter if we just do it like this
controls ctrl a ctrl c ctrl V is really
fast to do I'm sorry I'm on a Mac its
command so anyway so let's do save I
recommend quick save if you're working
in Salesforce save will take you back to
the original page and then you have to
hit edit again and go back in click save
let you stay on this page so let's do a
refresh and see how much of what we've
done what we've done is actually gonna
work okay not too bad it looks like our
colors are good
the border is good I I can see the
shadow great obviously the logo the
color here is I believe that's a green
it is but we do have an issue with with
this though showing up so that's one
thing we'll have to override and let's
check this out
oops we have a hover I had never took
away the hover effect so we want to get
rid of that okay so let's let's do that
so two things we need to do get rid of
these guys and then get rid of that
hover effect so let me do the hover
first so I don't forget because the
icons are a lot more obvious so let's
inspect that and what we're gonna do so
this is the the element that we're going
to be working with we can go in here and
dev tools and click on hover and then
click the box for hover and so now we
don't have to move our mouse over this
it's going to be permanently hovered
until we uncheck this and now we can see
the hover styles so let's grab let's
just let's grab all of this and but set
transparent as the background color
right normally we wouldn't be setting
transparent as a background color that's
ridiculous right but remember we're not
going to directly edit this file so we
have to think how can we override
everything so actually let me see by
default ever see where I want to put
this thing
I'm gonna put it here
yeah that makes sense we're going to
have to give a little bit of thought to
our net organization of our code and
actually I messed up on my um on my
workflow here it should have gone here
first
I guess it doesn't matter we could do it
either way it might save us a step if we
just did it all here but I wouldn't kind
of like to have a separate copy okay so
you have that here say that there and so
that should be taken care of and then
finally let's go in here and inspect
this and make sure it should be this
before you know what maybe we edited the
wrong thing
let's take a look at this again
hmm
that's interesting
oops I think we we went to the wrong
before so well yeah we just need to edit
our CSS so let's go ahead and do that
I'm not even gonna test it in dev tools
because I target header user okay
because I am 99% sure that this will
work just like this we'll just amend
this here all right now let's let's give
it another test before we move on quick
save this kind of thing really makes you
appreciate live reloading great okay so
that works now No
okay we've done something wrong here
let's double check what we had here in
our code whoops this is the problem
his parents
okay great now that that does work
awesome
you know what I think we have a hover
effect right here on this text I can
barely see it
good let's see probably on this span
let's check out the hover on the span no
let's check out the hover here yep there
we go okay so on this this a tag we have
a hover effect where the color changes
yeah I mean that's not a huge deal you
can barely tell but I'll I'll see it so
let me change that okay this will be an
easy change just without we're going to
do that we're just going to go a to a
target etc user
we're going to add this on here
area and that should work
okay I'm not even gonna test that that's
that's definitely gonna work okay
awesome so we've got a totally
redesigned header I don't want to say
totally I mean it we didn't do that much
here right and we just remove some
things but now this already just because
we did the header I think this already
looks like a Franciscan University
website according to the the updated
styles that we've been using so awesome
awesome that looks a million times
better than then would it look like an
hour ago
sorry that sounded like I was I was
bragging on there I'm just I'm not I
didn't mean for it to come out like that
I'm just happy that this all worked out
and it I'm happy with the way it looks
right now all right so let me check out
the time eight minutes okay let's see
just see what we'll do nice let's just
take this image out of here
you know what I'm gonna see if I can
find the actual element where this image
is because here's what I don't want to
happen
I don't want us we could test this out
for sure but what I'm afraid might
happen is that this image would somehow
get loaded anyway if we just try to
override it so let's see what what this
image is yeah it's probably it's a
background image so yeah I don't want it
to accidentally get loaded
next - word hero so if we can find this
let's just try to remove it target X
dashboard here oh I have a feeling that
we're not gonna find it in the file but
it's worth a shot so let's go back to
our template file and find target X
dashboard here whoa did you really find
it crazy all right
oops let me make this bigger sorry I am
I don't know why I forgot to make this
bigger all right so let's see wow we do
have this here amazing target X - 4 hero
all right so let's see what we can move
you know what I want to remove this
entire thing there's no reason why we
need Franciscan University student will
here when we have it right here we have
the logo here it's entirely redundant
and unnecessary let's just get rid of
this entire section they're calling a
hero section here and then we don't have
to worry about trying to fit our logo
into here this is going to save us a lot
of time and I don't think that we're
really gonna lose very much
aesthetically by getting rid of this
section and it's definitely gonna be
worth it for the amount of time we'll
save so let's for now I'm just gonna
comment these out I do have a backup of
this so we can mess it up as much as we
want and I have backups but for now I
think it's which it's still better if we
just comment it out and then it'll make
it that much easier to bring it back if
somebody sees that and freaks out and
wants it back
so insert hero alright so I'm hoping
that I don't get an error by taking
things out but let's let's find out I
know when we were working with c-sharp
and we try to take some of the stuff out
we got an error and we had to do some
other stuff but this should be fun I was
afraid that would happen
shoot
you know I'm just gonna take this out
and user use your name shoot
hold on a second I want to see what this
is and if this is going to be important
at some point
yeah
okay
I think I do want to keep this this
little user that's kind of a nice thing
a nice personalized thing
it was commented out though and I don't
know if they just it was in there just
for a demo of what it could do
you know what let's log in and see what
this really does on the interior pages
so we're gonna need to sign up so it's
great I bet I get admissions pamphlets
and stuff mailed to me not maybe if I
use my Franciscan do you address
somebody in admissions will realize that
like I have a user already
all right fine then let's use a
different email just a while Jima
it actually wouldn't be a bad idea for
me to get these mailings I'd like to see
and then that way if there's any UI
issues with the emails that they send
out to prospective students I'll be able
to see them where's my email
okay well so the email that gets sent
out check that out so that could
definitely use some work I don't know
how much control we have over that but
there's a few things obviously it's not
aesthetically pleasing at all I'm not
the best at making emails but so I'm not
really shouldn't be talking about this
but that could use some improvement and
look at the email the from email JRM
team dot franciscan so this is not it
should not be that it shouldn't be JRM
team at Frances the Franciscan agenda
board calm all right well I don't think
I can change that right now off there
just deal with it later on
all right so I'm going to create a
password
on my other screen
okay so I was making sure that I added
all of that it's the last pass I don't
forget it
so let's let's login
whoa
interesting
all right so we're dealing with
and this is using angular for this this
looks like angular they are okay so the
once you login it's using angular ok
so I guess we're gonna have to do a
whole different set of styles for all
the interior pages alright well good to
know you're not gonna get to it today
but definitely need some work okay so
that's taking a lot longer than I would
expect all right so my 25 minute timer
is up and yeah it's definitely up so I'm
gonna go back to the live chat I'm gonna
go through all the questions now and
then trying to think if there is
something now for some reason I thought
there was something I want something
else I wanted to do but now I can't
think of it so I'm just going to go over
the questions in the live chat so pick
up where we left off after the last
break so we're done with the coding
portion of it which is good because I
can't get this page to refresh now
anyway but really nice definitely I for
sure wanted to get the header finished
today and we accomplished that we
actually got a little bit farther and
started checking out the code for that
hero section so it was a good day and
hopefully you all got something out of
that just for some CSS stuff I um wasn't
quite as interactive as normal mostly
because I hey I don't need as much help
with the CSS alright so let me find out
where I left off okay so the all right I
can't pronounce his PA t vq i'm just
gonna say the pat so the pat says hello
i want to build a simple portfolio blog
site so i can update my progress so make
posts in learning coding do you know any
tutorial with Django or nodejs blog
creation yeah
there's a there's a lot of different
tutorials that you could go to I guess
it kind of depends on how complicated
you want to make it if if you want to do
this project of a blog as a learning
experience then you could try to make
one from scratch using node or Django or
whatever you want if the goal is just to
get a blog up and running as fast as
possible so you can you know start
posting things then you could just run a
wordpress blog very simply they have the
five minute install which I mean
literally it is five minutes or less
so that would be the simplest thing to
do but if you wanted to get a little bit
more complex you could use what's it
called
is it Jekyll is that is that the like
the static site kind of creator that a
lot of people use for blogging there's
something else too it's a ghost I can't
remember all the names of it but yeah
you can definitely you can get a blog up
and running you know in less than an
hour if you just do a simple WordPress
blog or you can be more common if you
wanted to get really complex and just
work on your skills you could check out
what we've done with the WordPress API
and react and nodejs in our previous
streams of project one project - and
project four were all in slightly
different ways basically building sites
that have blog functionality even though
we're not calling them blogs with
WordPress node and react so depending on
how complicated you want to get there's
a lot of options out there for you
Harshit says check traverse see media so
I've never looked anything from Travis
II but I have seen that recommended
before so check that out
Harris asked how well does free code
can't prepare you for
that's weird did that just take me to
the main page the homepage it did that
since that's not good oh shoot and
that's not even what I wanted that's
really weird actually let me take this
out now before somebody sees this
because I know this is probably a just a
demo user but I doubt that they would
want that let me remove that and this
[Music]
you just take the Sun okay there we go
never this looks like one of my sites
now right lots of white very plain the
point is a site like this will load so
fast right and users know what's gonna
happen so they know what they're
supposed to do anyway we'll clean this
up tomorrow
or some other Sun all right so it's re
harris i am i got sidetracked so the
question was how well does free code
can't prepare you for salesforce
development i learning the basics of
HTML CSS and JavaScript will prepare you
well for any kind of web development but
in particular Salesforce development has
a lot of things that are unique to
Salesforce so any course that's not
specifically Salesforce is not going to
fully prepare you for it but you just
see now we're making modifications to a
Salesforce visualforce page and we're
able to use so far basic HTML CSS so
that base will be able to it will help
you to to do a lot and then you can just
pick up some of the the more platform
specific things later on so the answer
is is I guess not fully so free code
kind of will not fully prepare you to
develop for Salesforce but it's going to
give you the necessary basic information
to be able to then build on and learn
some of those Salesforce specific things
so says rook says the screensaver behind
you is mesmerizing do I have a
screensaver me and I maybe it was on I
didn't even notice let me see I didn't
realize you could see that oh oh I guess
you can't see that screen this is a
really old Windows laptop that I have an
external monitor hooked up to and I
never use it it doesn't even have an
internet connection I used to use it for
testing but I just can't stand it it's
too slow I don't have patience to deal
with that old slow computers Blake says
I didn't catch what Salesforce's can you
react splain it rooks rook recommended
rewinding the livestream to see it I'll
give you a very short explanation though
in case you didn't do that or if anybody
else is interested Salesforce is a
platform that's mainly used by
businesses to track customers or
potential customers or clients get them
in a sales funnel and track them along
the progress of being a potential
customer - you know actually being you
know paying customer and then doing
remarketing and things like that so it
Salesforce can do a ton of stuff but I
think basically that's the main goal of
how a lot of people use sales was in our
case for my university we're using this
to help us organize the process that we
go through to attract potential students
and to have them you know actually go
through the process of enrolling and
coming to our University
okay Harshit says I guess it's pas a
platform as a service yeah yeah yes I
think that would be accurate
okay michael says regarding adam what
packages are you using uh-huh a lot of
faxes let me bring up let me show you my
config yeah I'm just gonna scroll slowly
through my packages
I don't know this isn't gonna give it
all is it shoot let me go to this you
then I forget what the file is that
shows all your packages
so I'll zoom in oh I can't I was
thinking I could save I'm just gonna
scroll through these slowly so that you
can check them out and then if you need
to you can pause the video or rewind it
later on okay
so into my packages
okay cool so some of you are saying
where are you from so Tennessee so let
me see so Dione is that let me know if
I'm pronouncing that wrong D IO and any
so I'm I'm thinking it's Dione but
correct me please if I'm wrong from
Tennessee so that's cool you're from
Tennessee I'm going to be in Tennessee
speaking at a conference at the end of
November so November 28th and 29th I
don't know what day I'm speaking yet but
I'll be in Nashville so if you're gonna
be around Nashville and can go to a
conference check it out it's called
November the tickets are still on sale
it's going to be on the on a campus at
Vanderbilt University so anyway check it
out if you can and I'll be there and if
you're there come and say hi to me also
if you have any recommendations for what
I should do when I am in Nashville
please let me know if anybody has some
natural recommendations cool Blake's
from South Carolina cool I like I love
Charleston South Carolina
that's one of my favorite cities it's
just I've I've rarely ever seen a city
so beautiful as Charleston and the food
there oh it's just amazing if you like
seafood Charleston is the place to go
let's see
haha Michael said that that email that I
showed earlier looked like a phishing
email yeah it does that's a good point
actually if I say that I think I'll
definitely get the access or get that
changed if I bring up the fact that it
looks like phishing email so I'm really
glad you said that Peter asks if I've
ever played bf1942 so battlefield 1942 I
have not
is it good should I play it but let me
is it a first-person shooter because if
it is I can't play it I get really
emotional a first-person shooters I
can't handle it
I used to take Dramamine which is a it's
a pill that you can take that makes you
it relieves motion sickness symptoms but
it also makes you really tired so I used
to take Dramamine at night play Call of
Duty I'd play with my dad and then play
until I was too tired and just fall
asleep otherwise I'd be so sick
michael says if you've got to fix that
it might be time to ask for a raise
actually I did I went to go make a joke
to my boss earlier but he wasn't in his
office but I was going to say hey now
that I officially graduated from the
Udacity react nano degree program I
think it's time that I get paid more
money I know that's not gonna happen
right now but I just wanted to mess with
him well maybe I'll check and see if
he's here after know the strength
okay cool allit Alessandra Alessandra or
Alessandra let me know which way to
pronounce it I don't want to mess it up
says Gatsby J s that's I think that's
what I was trying to think of Gatsby so
that's for the I'm sorry I this for the
blogging thing earlier we're talking
about an easy way to get started
blogging check out Gatsby jazz used it
yet but I've heard really good things
about it like at conferences and things
so I I recommend it in the sense that
I've I've heard that it's good okay cool
Dion thanks for the the help with the
pronunciation so it's Dion rhymes with
neon awesome that's a great way to
remember it
so Dion says what skills are
technologies do you consider to be
intermediate front-end there are no
junior level jobs in my area and a
recruiter suggests that I apply for
mid-level roles yeah definitely when it
comes to applying for jobs do not be
intimidated when you're trying when the
Job Description seems like it's beyond
which you can currently do apply anyway
sometimes those job descriptions are
written by people and Human Resources
who are good at what they do but they
have no idea what these coding terms
mean so they'll go into the IT
department or whatever department that's
hiring a coder and say what do you need
that coder to be able to do and they'll
list a bunch of things that they'd like
the person to do and then the HR person
just puts them all down on a list not
realizing that this kind of seems
ridiculous to have somebody with all
these different skills or I've dealt
with that process of trying to make a
job description that would make sense to
a coder even though it didn't make sense
to the HR people so anyway you never
know what's going on behind the scenes
with that so number
one this isn't exactly a question but
number one go for those jobs even if you
don't think you have the skills yet also
when it comes to intermediate front-end
skills this is really it's kind of hard
to it's hard to say for sure where that
line between beginner and intermediate
and then intermediate and expert is so I
it's not like we could really give an
exact you know place but I would say if
you are to the point where and like I
said this is entirely my opinion because
I don't know that there's any for sure
standard of what's intermediate but to
me is someone claim that they were an
intermediate level developer and were
supplying for a job to work here I would
want to see preferably on github I would
want to see that they've been able to
take a project completely build out the
project connect to api's pull in data
work with forms form validation handling
form data I would want to see that
they're able to use javascript
techniques beyond just jQuery so whether
that be some sort of framework like
react angular paraview or others or
whether that be they're using vanilla
JavaScript or whatever but I want to see
their beyond that I'd like also to see
depending on the job it would be nice to
see some custom CSS work so that they're
going beyond just a normal framework the
frameworks are really nice and I
recommend using them whenever you can
but it's nice to know that someone can
adapt it as necessary so those are the
skills that I would be looking for just
in general it's hard to say you know
because so much depends on specifically
the the job and what needs to be done
but but the big things are they can do
things from scratch with the
that makes sense or adaptive framework
they can do more than just basic jQuery
and actually do some more advanced
JavaScript things that can potentially
mean being able to handle using a
framework and if it's like reacting a
frame where they can manage state
properly and then can they interact with
api's can they pull data make sure that
you know make sure that their sites are
checking you go they're check-in these
they're validating their form inputs are
they checking to make sure that when you
know data comes and when it's not when
it's not there are they providing fall
backs like you know error messages like
things that things that separate the
work from being like just a project that
you're doing and being something that is
actually deployable live and is reliable
anyway so that was probably kind of
vague I'm sorry if it if it was too
vague for you but hopefully that that
helps a little bit but in general my
advice for that kind of thing is just
keep working and keep pushing yourself
and doing projects and keep applying you
just you never know what's really going
on
and when a job description is created so
it's worth a shot to applied it to
anything that you're even remotely
interested in okay Blake said did you
see my question on Ajax I did not let me
scroll up okay I'm sorry Blake I don't
know how I missed that
Blake's question is I'm sending data to
a Google sheet using Ajax and in two of
my fields I get undefined
docs.google.com spreadsheet oh okay I
checked all my name attributes code is
like two on this up state all right let
me check I actually have your your
github
open right now on another in another
window so it's github upstate okay so
this is assuming it's in contact je s
yeah that's for your sending a Google
sheet okay I'll check that out after the
shingon all the time it is yeah if I
have time today I'll check it out after
the stream otherwise maybe I'll check it
out tomorrow and I'll let you know
maybe I'll just submit a pull request I
don't know we'll see
anyway I see it now sorry I missed that
before Blake I've worked with sending
form data to Google sheets before so
hopefully I'll be able to sort it out
now I won't be able to see what code you
have going on on your Google sheet in
Google Apps Script so if the problem is
on that side of things obviously I can't
do it and I won't be able to fully test
it out so if it's something obvious that
I can see I can help with otherwise I
probably won't be able to help I can
always maybe try to make my own she will
see how much time I have
okay Deon says darn I have to work
is it live-streamed actually I I don't
think it's gonna be live-streamed we
actually add so on Twitter there was a
conversation back and forth between the
people that are running the conference
and somebody from the livestream who was
it I can't remember now who it was about
live streaming stuff from the conference
from November and it didn't seem like it
was going to happen that it would be
live streamed so probably won't get live
streamed if the Internet's good enough I
might try to shoot some footage if I'm
allowed in either live stream it or
upload it to YouTube it's going to place
it'll depend on the quality of the
internet there so I'll try to put out
some content no matter what I know the
keynote talks are going to be put on
YouTube I don't think they'll be live
streamed so I may or may not my talk may
or may not be on YouTube so we'll see
how cool Blake says it's nice so we when
I was talking about Charleston South
Carolina Blake says it's nice I live in
Greenville it's probably the second
nicest cool I've never been to
Greenville maybe I've five a chance off
to check out Greenville to
okay Deon says thanks for your input to
my question you're welcome
they said hopefully that that had helped
let me know if you have any follow-up
questions or anything either in the
stream or you can send me a message on
Twitter or whatever social media be more
than happy that answer any questions you
have especially if it's something more
specific sometimes people prefer to ask
more specific questions over you know
Twitter or something like in a direct
message so I'm I'm up for that too
sometimes if I'm really busy I can't
always get back to you right away but
I'll try with it to get back to you
within a couple of days
okay Blake saying asking if I want the
Google script yeah actually if you could
send me the the Google script then that
would be helpful because then I could
make my own and and test it
Harris says what's your schedule like
how do you balance we're teaching plus
keep on learning more so I'm actually
not teaching so my work here is I'm a
full-time front-end developer so my
workday is it's supposed to be an
eight-hour workday but that includes one
hour for lunch
sometimes my hours are weird and it
doesn't work out like that but in
general that's pretty much my schedule
of work I usually work on Saturdays on
on learning more so if I have a class or
a client on the side I do that work on
Saturdays sometimes I do it before I
come to work and on my lunch breaks
occasionally I work at night during the
week so I don't really have a consistent
schedule for that other than Saturdays
so I don't like to always work on
Saturdays because I do want to spend
time with with my family and I for four
kids eight years old and under so I'll
probably be taking a break from working
on Saturdays now for for a while I'm I
don't know we'll see unless something
comes up like a project or client i I
don't maybe I'll take a break until till
after the new year he's I've been pretty
busy since basically this whole year
with side projects so that's kind of how
I managed to learn more with the
teaching thing I'm I was actually hoping
to be able to teach a little bit in the
computer science department this
semester but things kind of fell through
with I was planning on doing some sort
of team teaching thing but the schedule
of the teacher that I was team teaching
with things are a little weird it didn't
work out so I'm hoping that maybe next
year it'll happen I don't know that I
would want to teach an entire course all
by myself and deal with paperwork and
all that stuff but if I could team teach
and just come in and teach certain
topics and not how
to worry about all the other stuff the
administrative tasks that come along
with teaching I definitely be up for
that there's a web development course
here in the computer science department
that I would love to get in there and
you know teach some of the newer
techniques for web development but for
now I like doing what I'm doing so I
don't really have like a burning desire
to teach I used to teach high school and
it was nice but I'm not I love what I'm
doing right now so if it happens and I
get to teach that'll be cool because I'd
really like to help out the students
here and help them to get some good
experience on projects but I'm not
actively pursuing that if it happens it
happens and if in terms of the balance
the balance is hard so I don't always
feel like I have a balance between work
and and learning and my family so it's
just something you kind of just strive
for every day and if you mess up with it
and you get out of balance you try to do
better but it's just it's hard
especially with kids you can't always
plan everything out you know things
happen a kid gets sick and you got to
stay up all night with them or you know
that that throws off your schedule so
you just can't it's just hard to have
like a set schedule and plan things
when you have all those those unknown
variables with with the kids that demand
attention you can't just tell the kid
wait you know and I'll get to it
especially when you have babies like
they depend on you for everything so you
got to be there so I don't think there's
one like clear answer to getting that
perfect work-life balance you just got
to be ready to adapt you know and then
realize that sometimes you'll go through
periods where you're able to do a lot
one way or the other you may not be able
to have a perfect balance
every day so that you do these certain
things you know depends on your
situation Michael asked do you think
freelance sites like up work are worth
worth it to try out I'm not that
familiar with up work let me look
I haven't had great results with
freelance sites
okay upwork looks a lot like top towel
and I I haven't worked for top towel but
the concept looks the same and I
actually like the concept so the concept
is more like this up work or top towel
is the middleman and they try to pair
you up with clients and they handle all
the contracts paperwork payments all
that stuff and you just get to do the
work I'm actually a big fan of that
setup although like I said I haven't
worked for them for any you big company
like that so can't say about a personal
experience but I like that the sites
that I don't like and I don't think are
worth it or the sites where I think one
sites called freelancer freelancer yet
is where you go on there and it just
seems like people are doing work for for
nothing you know they're trying to
outbid each other
undercut the prices it did it just
doesn't seem worth it unless you have
nowhere else to go and you really need
to build up your portfolio people just
aren't being paid what they should be
what they're worth so then anyway that's
my opinion on it like I said I don't
have a ton of personal experience with
all the different kinds of sites that do
that that sort of thing so as long as if
the sites encouraging developers to
undercut each other in price I'd say
stay away from it if instead the site is
actually helping developers get paid
what they should get paid and making it
easier for them to find clients then
great I'm all for that so just check out
check out the site and see if you can
get ahold of people or talk to people
that that are actually working with that
company and see what they think
now Luke says the screensaver is back
okay I see it now I can see it in my
[Music]
that is kind of cool I never see it
because it's always behind me
Harris says here's an idea freakout cam
should provide productivity tips in
videos or vlog format yeah that would
actually be pretty cool I'd have to
think about it I could probably do
something
I certainly have complete freedom to
post videos on my own YouTube channel I
have to probably run it by Quincy if I
wanted to do a different style of video
but he'd probably be okay with it as
long as I came up with topics and the
quality was good so you think about that
and there probably other people that can
do it you have much better quality
videos than me and have better you know
better topics a better opinion so yeah
but that's a good idea I'll keep that in
mind yeah let me know what kind of
things you you all would like to hear
about and I can either work it in the
live stream or try to do videos and put
it on my youtube channel I'm I'm open to
suggestions
my screensaver is is keeping everybody's
attention now there we go you want me to
block try to block it out I guess I can
it's still there let's see okay sorry I
Harris says oh by teaching I meant these
live streams ok sorry that makes so much
more sense now I just I never think
about this as teaching it's because I
it's it's way more collaborative than
normal teaching so that makes a lot of
sense that sorry I misunderstood so
Harris says I meant by a teaching I
meant these live streams I had a
professor who ended up teaching half the
semester through a youtube live that's
really cool
I would that I would like to do it like
that not have to actually go into the
classroom and just I think it would be
easier because if I'm teaching like I
want to I'm teaching code stuff the most
important thing is that people can see
my screen see what's on it so it would
almost be better if I just live stream
then all the students could have the
code right there on their computers
anyway okay yeah so the good actually
there is one way there's one key reason
why I'm able to do these streams and
stream as frequently and as long as I do
and that is because I get to stream
while I'm at work so that's why I work
on the projects that I need to for my
job and so in that sense I can't always
work on what I really want to but it's
fine I think we still do good good
projects and because I can do it at work
it doesn't cut into my time that I would
have with my family so it would be hard
for me to be able to spend this much
time if it was taking time away
my family especially since I'm
volunteering you know it'd be hard to
explain to my wife that hey can you
watch the kids for another like three
hours every day so that I could do this
and we're not getting any more money so
you could see how that would be a hard
sell so thankfully my boss sees real
value and what I'm doing in terms of
several reasons one the University's
name gets out there to a lot of places
that no one probably was never heard of
this University before which is good
also I learned so much from you all you
can to contribute to project so these
projects end up being so much better
than they ever would be if it was just
me doing it so essentially my boss is
giving this time away by letting me work
on it for free code camp and in return
though the university is is gaining you
know some publicity and gaining some
expertise from you all so I think it's a
it's a very nice kind of trade-off there
so hopefully I can continue to do this
and it still is beneficial for for you
all for free code camp and for the
University and everything can keep
working out like this
[Music]
all right Rick asks what is the most
effective object-oriented programming
language to learn in a short timeframe
to land an entry job any suggestions I
don't have that much experience with
other programming languages but honestly
the easiest language for me to learn out
of all the other ones that I did that I
worked on
I don't know let me think about that for
a second
probably Python
yeah Python so just to give some context
I have worked with C++ C sharp PHP Java
and Python and some of that was just
doing basic tutorials but Python did
seem to be the easiest for me to pick up
so Python right now is really big with
machine learning and stuff like that so
if you're interested in that field then
I would check it out
also Python is cool because it's one of
the few programming languages that it's
really doable to code on a phone because
it's more about indentation and less
about special characters which usually
take several clicks to get to on a phone
so I actually learned Python on my
iPhone and by learned I mean like
learned enough to do really basic stuff
I'm not at all an expert on Python world
says do all frameworks use Ajax under
the hood no I don't they don't all use
Ajax and like I don't want to get into
obaid over what's the difference between
a framework and a library because we've
we've had that before but using like the
loose definition of those things if you
would want to consider react in that
general category of framework which I
know we've had debates before and it's
probably better called a library but
anyway someone like that doesn't
actually use anything so you're free to
use whatever you want so you could use
Ajax you could do just basic xhr you
could use fetch what's the other one
that people always like I can't remember
there's some other way to do it no it's
totally slipping my mind I always have
suggestions from people to use it but
anyway it doesn't actually come built-in
so I guess the answer would be no not
necessarily
okay I've gotten to the end of the live
chat I was just double-checking to make
sure I didn't miss anything if I did
miss something really sorry
you can ask it again in tomarrow stream
or send me a message on some social
media network let's see alright that's
it for today I should be back tomorrow I
don't think I have anything going on so
it should be around the normal time
somewhere around 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
I will be back we're probably going to
be working on this this app some more
this has been a project that I've had
since May and I keep putting it off
because it didn't need to be done so
finally I just want to get it done so
that when I finally get asked if I did
this
which nobody's asked me about it which
is another reason why I haven't done it
when I finally get asked if I did it I
can just say hey check it out and it'll
be done and and everyone will be
impressed
so it'll be this for a little while
until we get it done I don't think it'll
take that long hopefully not so anyway
I'll see you all tomorrow until then
have a great day